le budget des yvelines pour l'année 2010
est vient d'être votée par l'assemblée
départementale
il s'élève à 1,1 milliard d'euros pour
un total de dépenses de 970 millions
le département est l'un des plus
économes de france a rappelé son
président pierre bédier qui a également
promis de ne plus toucher à la fiscalité
pour les yvelinois je crois la nouvelle
la plus importante c'est la fiscalité
n'augmentera pas l'an passé le
département était contraint parce que
l'état nous avait pris près de 200
millions d'euros l'équivalent de 20 % de
notre budget nous avions été contraints
d'augmenter notre fiscalité cette année
nous avons absorber ce choc maintenir le
même niveau d'investissement qu'en 2016
sans augmenter les impôts
une équation difficile alors que le
département reçoit de moins en moins
d'argent de l'état certains postes de
dépenses ont été revues à la baisse
c'est le cas des subventions aux crèches
qui ont été supprimés aucune conséquence
de toute façon puisque les familles est
toujours la même somme puisque les
tarifs des crèches sont fixés par la caf
donc là il n'y a aucune modification des
tarifs payés par ailleurs les familles
dans les crèches
un dossier continuent d'entacher les
discussions au niveau départemental
celui du rapprochement avec les hauts de
seine
le projet permettrait de réaliser des
économies d'échelle et ce dès 2017 selon
ses défenseurs mais certains souhaitent
plus de détails
je pense principalement au transfert de
tout personnel sur tous les sites de
versailles sur un immeuble qui seraient
loués à guyancourt
c'est aujourd'hui officiel pour le
personnel n'était pas officielle ni pour
les élus ni à l'assemblée ni dans ce
budget enfin s'agissant de l'avenir le
département investira en priorité dans
les projets de mobilité telles que le
tram 13 et le prolongement du rer e